gentests vor der geburt die
krankenkassen zahlen künftig schwangeren
eine blutuntersuchung auf down syndrom
allerdings nur in einzelfällen endspurt
für den klimaschutz morgen will die
koalition festlegen was deutschland
gegen die erderwärmung tun wird die
letzten verhandlungen laufen
neuer verdacht gegen stefan der
generalbundesanwalt hat hinweise dass
der mutmaßliche attentäter kein
einzeltäter ist und eine weitere bluttat
verübt haben könnte
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
einen schönen guten abend wünsche ich
ihnen und herzlich willkommen tsum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann still doch familie
jahrelang hat das spitzengremium aus
ärzten kliniken und kassen darum
gerungen heute nun seine entscheidung in
begründeten einzelfällen zahlt die
krankenkasse schwangeren einen test der
untersucht ob ihr werden das kind
behindert sein könnte vor allem
behindertenverbände haben allerdings die
sorge dass dieser test zur regel wird
und kaum noch kinder mit behinderungen
zur welt kommen
seit 2012 gibt es den bluttests auf
mögliche trisomie wie das down-syndrom
aus dem blut der schwangeren wird das
erbgut des kindes isoliert und auf
gendefekte untersucht das kann die
riskantere fruchtwasseruntersuchung
ersetzen
bei und band ihn berichtet natalie kam
vor 20 jahren mit dem down syndrom zur
welt mit unterstützung ihrer mutter
meistert sie ihr leben vom
vorgeburtlichen bluttest der ihre
genetische besonderheit erkennen kann
hält sie nichts
sie sammelt unterschriften dagegen und
demonstriert bislang unterstützen die
krankenkassen vor allem tests wie die
fruchtwasseruntersuchung ein eingriff
der auch zu fehlgeburten führen kann
heute die entscheidung kassenleistung
wird jetzt auch ein bluttest bei
schwangerschaften mit besonderen risiken
verbunden mit ärztlicher beratung es
handelt sich nicht um eine routinemäßige
überprüfung bei jeder schwangerschaft
sondern es handelt sich in jedem fall
muss es sich handeln um eine
einzelfallentscheidung auch die
evangelische kirche war an der
diskussion beteiligt sie begrüßt den
entschluss mit der kassenleistung wird
eben zum ausdruck gebracht dass das in
einem gesellschaftlich verantwortlichen
rahmen ist und nicht als gegenstand von
ökonomie von werbung von
kommerzialisierung wichtig ist uns aber
eben auch dass diese gesellschaftliche
verantwortung und der gesellschaftliche
rahmen ausgedrückt wird und zum ausdruck
kommt durch eine umfassende
tische beratung der bluttest berührt
ethische grundfragen erhöht ein so
einfaches verfahren den druck auf frauen
ein kind ohne gehen anomalie zu gebären
werden die kritiker fürchten genetische
besonderheiten stigmatisiert der
entscheidende punkt für mich ist dass
dieser test wie viele andere
pränataldiagnostik shen verfahren kein
therapeutisches ziel verfolgen sondern
letztlich ein selektives ziel
natalie möchte dass menschen mit
down-syndrom nicht an den
gesellschaftlichen rand gedrängt werden
weil sie in die mitte gehören alles über
die ethische debatte zu den bluttest
können sie auch auf heute de nachlesen
dort finden sie zudem eine fakten box zu
den gängigen vorgeburtlichen
untersuchungen im fall des ermordeten
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübke gibt es neue erkenntnisse zum
einen scheint sich der verdacht zu
erhärten dass der tatverdächtige
rechtsextreme stephanie nicht allein
handelte zum anderen hat er offenbar
2016 versucht einen irakischen
asylbewerber zu töten
einzelheiten von stefan schlosser und
andreas christian der täter näherte sich
auf einem fahrrad von hinten ohne
vorwarnung sticht einem 22 jahre alten
flüchtling aus dem irak in den rücken
und verletzte ihn schwer
nach auffassung der bundesanwaltschaft
könnte stephanie auch für diese tat
verantwortlich seien geschehen nur
unweit von seinem wohnhaus motiv hass
gegen ausländer als mutmaßlicher mörder
des kasseler regierungspräsidenten sitzt
bereits seit juni in untersuchungshaft
genauso wie markus h der im die
mordwaffe vermittelt haben soll
nach bisherigen ermittlungserkenntnissen
hat markus h aber deutlich mehr getan
in einem beschluss zu einer
haftbeschwerde geht der bgh von einer
gemeinsamen radikalisierung und weiteren
unterstützung aus somit bestärkte der
beschuldigte mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit dessen entschluss den
mordanschlag auf dr lücke tatsächlich
auszuführen
die akten legen nahe dass auch die
ermittler nicht mehr wie anfangs
vermutet von nur einem rechtsextremen
einzeltäter ausgehen
die linke spricht sogar von einem
netzwerk wir gehen davon aus dass das
eine gemeinsam geplante tat war und dass
er unterstützer gehabt hat und dass
dieser unterstützungs kreis auch der
gleich ist der seinerzeit im nsu komplex
aufgetaucht ist stephanie ist mehrfach
straffällig geworden und vorbestraft
seit 2010 sei aber nach angaben des
verfassungsschutzes nicht mehr auffällig
gewesen und vom radar verschwunden seit
dieser zeit soll er sich zusammen mit
markus h weiter radikalisiert haben
alles was jetzt zusätzlich rauskommt
dann informationen bestätigt uns darin
dass wir nicht nachvollziehen können
warum die behörden aufgehört haben ihn
zu beobachten
auch der angriff auf den iraker wurde
stefanie lange nicht zugeordnet dabei
hatte ihn die polizei im zusammenhang
mit dieser tat bereits 2016 überprüft
allerdings ohne ergebnis
die union streitet darüber wie die im
mittelmeer geretteten migranten in
europa verteilt werden sollen
innenminister seehofer hatte angeboten
ein viertel von ihnen in deutschland
aufzunehmen und sofort hagelte es kritik
parteifreunde meinen man dürfe keine
anreize setzen
jetzt wird sich der minister das blatt
berichtet 2199 flüchtlinge haben es in
den letzten 15 monaten über das
mittelmeer nach europa geschafft noch
immer gibt es kein vorteil mechanismus
in der eu
dass er dafür kritisiert wird generell
ein viertel der geretteten migranten
nach deutschland zu holen ärgert den
innenminister sichtlich ich weise die
kritik an diesem verfahren aufs
schärfste zurück es ist unglaublich dass
man sich als bundesinnenminister für die
rettung von menschen vor dem ertrinken
rechtfertigen muss seehofer reagiert auf
kritik die auch und vor allem aus den
eigenen reihen kommt
wenn man dagegen dass man von vornherein
gegen welche quoten festlegt dies ist
eine unbegrenzte zahl von menschen wir
wissen ja nicht nur auf 25 prozent
damit wird ein neuer anreiz geschaffen
werden und der ist jedenfalls nicht
richtig rückendeckung wenn auch recht
verhalten bekommt seehofer von seinem
amtsnachfolger humanität ist
selbstverständlich ergibt sich bei uns
aus dem ursprung auch unsere parteien
gründung als christliche parteien und
umgekehrt ist aber auch wichtig dass
darüber die ordnung erhalten bleibt
deutlicher positioniert sich die spd
dass deutschland hilft auch mit einem
solchen anteil hilft das ist erstmal
richtig und deswegen gibt es das volle
unterstützung der spd
was wir schaffen müssen es eine
europäische regelung und das sagen wir
schon seit langem
am kommenden montag trifft sich seehofer
mit anderen eu innenministern um erneut
über ein vorteil mechanismus für
flüchtlinge zu verhandeln
ein großer wurf soll es werden endlich
schluss sein mit dem klein-klein in der
klimapolitik die große koalition selbst
hat die latte hoch gelegt für ihr klima
paket
morgen soll es stehen im moment laufen
die letzten großen verhandlungen dazu im
kanzleramt
bislang zeichnet sich ab es wird wohl
eine abwrackprämie für alte ölheizungen
geben und auch zuschüsse beim kauf eines
e-autos die große streitfrage aber
bleibt wie wird der co2 ausstoß teurer
über eine steuer wie es die spd fordert
oder wie es die union will über den
handel mit verschmutzungsrechten
unterleib energy ist vor dem kanzleramt
in berlin wo seit eineinhalb stunden
wieder gerungen wird stark unterlag wird
das was mit dem großen wurf
also vermutlich nicht wenn er nicht noch
einige lücken geschlossen werden heute
ist ja ein entwurf eines
klimaschutzprogramms für zwanzig dreißig
hier bekannt geworden 137 seiten hinter
mir im kanzleramt auch verhandelt werden
und da klaffen eben doch noch einige
lehrstellen zum beispiel bei der co2
reduzierung da hat man sich bis 2030 300
millionen tonnen vorgenommen die man
einsparen will
bisher reichen die vorschläge nicht aus
nicht mal die hälfte ist da erreicht
wenn man das zusammen
in diesem entwurfspapier das endstand
von montagabend hat da wird sicherlich
noch nachgearbeitet worden seien aber
muss auch noch nachgearbeitet werden
der rest der einsparungen soll dann über
den erhöhten co2 preis kommen wo man
aber auch noch nicht genau weiß wie das
funktionieren wird also mit welchen
mitteln und dann gibt es auch noch eine
lücke im text bei den kosten es ist
nicht klar was da der klimaschutz in
zukunft kosten wird auch da werden alle
noch einmal den kopf zusammen stecken
müssen von den grünen gibt es schon
kritik an diesem infos papier das heißt
es ist alles noch nicht konkret genug
bis morgen mittag will sich die
koalition hier auf jeden fall einigen
und alle beteiligten sagen das wird eine
sehr lange nacht der dankeschön für
diese einschätzung container banerjee
ins ausland ganz anderes thema wer ist
schuld an dem super gau von fukushima
juristisch gesehen vorerst niemand drei
frühere top manager des betreibers tepco
sind jetzt vor gericht freigesprochen
worden
gut acht jahre nach dem atomunglück
infolge eines seebebens und tsunamis
damals kam es in drei reaktoren zur
kernschmelze
160.000 anwohner mussten fliehen
seitdem versucht tepco die strahlung in
der atomruine in den griff zu bekommen
über juristische und moralische schuld
stephanie schöne baum demonstranten
betroffene ankläger haben sich vor dem
bezirksgericht in tokio versammelt sie
warten auf das urteil für einen prozess
der überhaupt erst auf ihren druck den
der bürger zustande kam und das gericht
hat entschieden
freispruch für die früheren topmanager
des japanischen kraftwerksbetreibers
tepco
die menschen hier sind sauer
entsprechend höheren rufen sie
wir werden diese ungerechtigkeit nicht
hinnehmen das ist wirklich unglaublich
das ist ein unglaubliches urteil
was passiert nun mit unserem japan ist
doch so es ist wirklich erschreckend
berufliche fahrlässigkeit mit todesfolge
so lautete die anklage
der vorwurf die top-manager sollen schon
2008 gewusst haben dass in fukushima 1
zu namen drohte der eine höhe von knapp
16 metern erreichen könnte und somit den
vorhandenen schutzwall weit übersteigen
würde
sie hätten gewusst dass es zu einem
stromausfall und somit zu einer atom
katastrophe kommen könnte ebene novelty
trotz des freispruchs werden diese
menschen hier nicht aufgeben und in
tempo und die regierung zur
verantwortung zu ziehen
auch um eine weitere atom katastrophe zu
verhindern
mit diesem freispruch hat die regierung
ihr verbrechen begraben
für ein ziel der staat und das
unternehmen müssen geschützt werden
bis heute sind weite teile um fukushima
radioaktiv verseucht sperre belegt das
urteil wurde damit begründet dass der
tsunami und die atomkatastrophe nicht
vorhersehbar gewesen sein
vor allem könne man kein atomkraftwerk
betreiben wenn der betreiber
verpflichtet wäre alle risiken zu
berücksichtigen
tunesiens ex machthaber ben ali ist tot
er starb 83-jährige im saudi arabischen
exil
mehr als 20 jahre hatte er in tunesien
regiert geld dabei zunächst als
modernisierer und wirtschaftlichere
forma entwickelte sich aber immer mehr
zum autoritären machthaber im arabischen
frühling 2011 war ben ali der erste
herrscher der region der gestürzt wurde
zweieinhalb wochen nach der landtagswahl
in brandenburg zeichnet sich ab mit wem
die spd regieren könnte
ministerpräsident woidke hat der spd
landesspitze koalitionsverhandlungen mit
cdu und grünen vorgeschlagen
bei den grünen entscheidet darüber ein
kleiner parteitag am samstag die grünen
politikerin renate künast muss derbe
beschimpfungen auf facebook unter
bestimmten umständen hinnehmen
das entschied das landgericht berlin und
sprach von zulässige meinungsäußerungen
hintergrund sind facebook kommentare zu
einem zeitungsbericht der nahelegt dass
köhlers 1986 mit einem zwischenruf im
berliner abgeordnetenhaus sex mit
kindern bagatellisiert habe axel konrad
und felix zimmermann mit diesem posting
ging der shitstorm 20.15 los eine fast
30 jahre alte äußerung von renate künast
wurde von einem rechten blogger auf
facebook verfälscht wiedergegeben was
folgte waren beschimpfungen von denen
wir nur die harmloseren zeigen
künast klagte wollte die
personenbezogenen daten von 22 nutzern
das landgericht berlin lehnte ab mit der
begründung die äußerungen seien im
zusammenhang mit einer fehde für die
debatte gefallen
durch diesen zusammenhang hat das
landgericht berlin die auffassung
vertreten die 27 zivilkammer dass es im
ergebnis noch als zulässige
meinungsäußerung zu bewerten sei und
keine straftaten darstellen würden
renate künast sieht in dem urteil einen
angriff auf den kernbestand der
demokratie ihr anwalt und dann hat das
mit großer bestürzung aufgenommen also
hielt es nicht für möglich dass solche
schweren anfeindungen hier auch noch die
rückendeckung von gerichten halten in
deutschland auch medienanwalt christian
schertz kann das urteil überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen wieso unsere hits
missbrauch begrenzung durch einen
rechtsstaat durch den gesetzgeber aber
auch durch mutige gerichte und ich finde
dass kontaktiert auch die arbeit der
ermittlungsbehörden und der
staatsanwaltschaft nicht extra abteilung
eingeführt haben um diese paarung im
netz diese beleidigung die inzwischen um
sich greifen denen eine grenze zu setzen
künast will gegen das urteil vorgehen
was ist zulässige kritik was ist
beleidigung der richterspruch in berlin
hat diese grenze zumindest vorläufig
verschoben
freitags auf die autobahn keine gute
idee in der ferienzeit noch weniger denn
dann ist die staugefahr mit abstand am
größten weist der adac und hat die
zahlen für 2009 10 zwischen dem 21
juni und dem 8 september zählte der
automobilclub insgesamt 594 staus mit
mehr als zehn kilometern länge
das waren rund 16 prozent mehr als 2008
die gründe sind wenig überraschend
baustellen und hohes verkehrsaufkommen
und damit sind wir beim sport wieder top
und da haben die bayern zum sechzehnten
mal in folge ihr erstes spiel in der
gruppenphase gewonnen 13 uhr gegen roter
stern belgrad ein eher unspektakulärer
arbeitssieg spektakulär dagegen der
auftritt von bayern präsident uli hoeneß
nach dem spiel freude strahlen wird
bayern ein zufriedener trainer kovac es
ist eigentlich ein entspannter abend
gestern in münchen commander vorarbeit
von perisic lewandowski im zusammenspiel
mit der gästeabwehr und müller
schlitzohrig im duett mit tiago belgrad
kontrolliert keine probleme auf dem
platz aber dann drehte bedarf bei uli
hoeneß rückendeckung für torwart manuel
neuer thema die torwart diskussion im
nationalteam verstecken ist ein sehr
guter torwart aber manuel neuer ist doch
viel besser
ich hätte mir auch vom dfb mehr
unterstützung erwartet für den dfb
antwortet heute oliver bierhoff neuer
hatte in zwölf länderspielen seit der wm
zehn mal komplett durchgespielt das sind
doch eindeutige und ganz entscheidende
statements der trainer höhne slick
nachfolgenden verhaltener handelnden
personen hätte ich schon erwartet dass
man den hastigen schon mal in die ecke
stellt und immer klar sagt dass es so
nicht geht
er beschädigt hier einen völlig
untadeligen sportsmann
es sind sportlich entspannte tage in
münchen für den wirbel abseits des
rasens sorgt der präsident leverkusen
dagegen es mit einer krachenden
heimniederlage gestartet bayer verlor 1
2 gegen den vermeintlich leichtesten
gruppengegner lokomotive moskau und
zeigte insgesamt eine schwache leistung
und im gestrigen top spiel der
königsklasse hat paris st real madrid
mit 3 zu 0 düpiert auch ohne die
superstars nehmer und mp dafür aber mit
dem aria ein ehemaliger madrilene der
zwei tore schoss aline rotter focken
holt die dritte bronzemedaille für die
deutschen ringer bei der wm in
kasachstan
die ex weltmeisterin gewann das kleine
finale in der höchsten gewichtsklasse
bis 76 kilogramm gegen die
lokalmatadorinnen mira system koffer
damit haben sich schon zwei deutsche
ringerinnen und drei ringer für die
olympischen spiele in tokio qualifiziert
und morgen hat anna schell in der klasse
bis 68 kilogramm ebenfalls die chance
auf bronze und wir schauen jetzt noch
auf den traum zum fliegen
das war nur ein traum bis otto
lilienthal kam lilienthal wurde zum
vorbild vieler luftfahrtpioniere als er
1891 nach potsdam seinen ersten
gleitflug erfolgreich beendete dass
seine geräte fliegen könnten konnten
haben jetzt mitarbeiter vom deutschen
zentrum für luft und
bewiesen in kalifornien weil solche
versuche hierzulande verboten sind
musste das team in die usa ausweichen
das wetter verspricht für die meisten
auch morgen wieder sonne an den küsten
gibt es aber auch mal eine kleine dusche
die details hat gleich gunther tiersch
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie marietta slomka und hier ist
morgen wieder christian sievers dran
haben sie noch einen schönen abend
bleiben sie uns gewogen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau über zuschauer die luft ist ja bei
uns sehr trockenen deshalb wird es
nachts ziemlich kühl bei uns bodenfrost
ist wieder angesagt aber in den nächsten
tagen wird es dann doch langsam wärmer
und schon morgen haben wir dann
höchsttemperaturen im westen von 20 grad
kühler bleibt es noch im osten und so
richtig herbstlich frisch und kalt im
norden skandinaviens fünf bis zehn grad
nachts bis minus 5 grad
ein bisschen frostig wird es auch bei
uns in der nacht im östlichen bayern
minus zwei grad und in der mitte in den
mittelgebirgen aber auch im süden zum
teil bodenfrost während es doch im
norden deutlich milder ist da haben wir
erst einmal den klaren himmel wie auch
im übrigen deutschland aber morgen früh
wird es bewölkt aber vielleicht gibt es
dann auch schon erste kleine
regenschauer an der nordsee die ziehen
tagsüber dann weiter über die küste nach
osten vielleicht auch mal kommen sie bis
nach brandenburg und berlin bei diesem
frischen kräftigen westen in der mitte
und im süden aber wer in dieses wetter
wie heute blauer himmel kaum wolken
sonnig und dazu dieser mäßiger ostwind
am rhein hier da wird es dann am
wärmsten temperaturen schon von 19 bis
22 grad sonst sind es meist noch 15 bis
17 grad aber es wird ja wärmer am
wochenende dazu überwiegend sonnig erst
am montag in der neuen woche
da wird es dann wechselhafter und auch
wieder etwas kühler
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut